all right um let's get started for today
um welcome to class we'll have two
topics today semi-supervised learning
and unsupervised distribution alignment
before we do that a quick Roundup of
where we're at in the
semester so we're a little over halfway
through homework four was due yesterday
maybe some of you are using lat days
still working on it uh that's fine but
if you're running everything on time
you're done with your last homework for
this class then today we'll have
actually it's lecture 10 my top slide
was wrong it's already lecture 10 semi-
supervised learning and UNS supervised
distribution
alignment um then next week is spring
break week here at Berkeley so there's
no lecture week after that we'll cover
compression and also so um the Friday
two weeks from tomorrow your uh project
Milestone is due this means you are
expected to have made some progress on
your project and write
three-page uh report into a Google doc
to share with us so we can look at it
give you some feedback make suggestions
or just tell you it's looking good and
you're doing great or maybe tell you hey
it's not looking good uh better ramp it
up then um the week after that we'll
have a combination midterm and lecture
so in the next week or so we'll generate
a midterm study handout don't worry
about it too much it's just going to be
like anywhere you know 10 to 15 pages of
um equations and it'll be question
answer question answer and at the
midterm we'll just ask you three of the
questions you know the questions ahead
of time there'll only be a 10 possible
questions maybe 15 you'll get three out
of those you write them out on a piece
of paper the answers if you want to
memorize that's great but ideally you I
mean memorization we know gives deep
understanding next token prediction is
all all you need so I'm not going to
argue against memorizing what's on on
those on those answers we provide but uh
you know there will be no questions in
the exam because the questions you know
them ahead of time you know what the
anwers are going to be so no
clarification questions you just get the
sheet of paper you get I don't know 20
minutes half an hour to write you know
three pages of answers and um after that
we'll have a regular lecture that will
be in a different
room um then we'll have two guest
lectures on uh our last week Thursday
one on AI for science another one on
well two lectures combined on neres
neural Radiance fields and then we'll
have our final lecture that Friday so
we'll have a Friday lecture that week um
and then the last week of classes in the
regular schedule we won't have a lecture
because we took the lecture a week
earlier on Friday so that's what's ahead
and then your final project reports and
final project of video presentations
will be due on May 10 any any questions
on
Logistics
yes um yeah they will or if we see that
they are becoming very quiet because
maybe was busy because of homework and
then mid final projects it turns out
less busy maybe we'll we'll we'll replan
something
um but for now they'll they'll remain
the
same okay so
um I want to cover two topics today
semi-supervised learning and
unsupervised distribution alignment it's
kind of an interest interesting set of
topics to cover because I think
intellectually there is a lot of
richness in these topics um I find them
pretty exciting at the same time they
have not been the most active topics of
research recently um somehow you know I
think the field has shifted to just very
large scale pre-trading on massive data
sets as opposed to looking specifically
at these
ideas um it could be that they're a
thing of the past and they'll never make
a comeback um or it could be that you
know maybe it's the right time for them
to to make a comeback or at least for
certain types of settings make it
comeback we we'll see um so semi survice
learning I think this picture kind of
explains pretty well what the problem
setting is obviously we want to do it in
higher Dimensions but supervisor
learning is the thing on the left you're
given a bunch of data points you're
given the classification labels and then
you're supposed to find a decision
boundary um this by the way it's called
like a half two half moon
configuration all the way on the right
unsupervised learning you have no labels
maybe you could still argue that you
could maybe recover that there's two
clusters if you're doing very good
unsupervised learning you just don't
know what the labels are going to be and
the middle semi- supervisor learning is
something in between most of your data
has no labels but then some data has
labels if you look at it you could say
oh maybe I could hope that you know
given where the blue labels are I could
like propagate those labels to nearby
unlabeled ones and from there discover
that that entire half moon should be
blue and same for the other half one
that it should be
um yellow orange um so that's what semi
supervis learning ultimately is about is
to expand from the labels you have onto
nearby unlabeled examples to refine your
decision Browning Because by the way if
all you train on is the labeled examples
in the middle
picture you you lose a lot of the
structure in the problem but by also
using the unlabeled examples and how you
decide where you're going to draw your
decision boundary you can get a much
better solution so that's the idea in
semisupervised
learning so classification is the
typical setting um by default we know uh
it's done fully supervised you have
training data consisting of image and
label predict label for new images let's
say semiservis what if we have a few
labeled samples and many unlabeled
samples um why because label is
generally more time consuming than
collecting data so you can imagine that
it's cheaper to get more data than it is
to get more labeled data hence why the
setting could make a lot of sense um so
in semi supervised learning the goal is
to use the unlabeled data to make the
supervised learning yield a better
result historically the belief of many
machine learning practitioners was that
semi- supervised learning definitely
helps in the low data regime but once
you have a lot of data it doesn't really
help anymore it's you know collect just
more and more data that there's just
enough labeled data so no need to do the
semi-supervised tricks and because
there's additional trickery involved
maybe it makes you do worse even um and
the dream used to be to bring that curve
above fully above no matter the data
regime um above supervised and that's
definitely become true um over time so
the curve on the right is the current
state of affairs which we'll see um
towards the end of this first half of of
lecture um um but that didn't used to be
the case until people discovered really
better and better ways to do
semisupervised
learning so formally the way the problem
is set up is you have in supervised
learning you have X and Y X is the input
Y is the output they come from a chint
distribution over X and Y and then you
try to maximize let's say the log
probability of Y given X in a maximum
likelihood learning setting maybe with
some
regularization
in semi- supervis learning you have two
data sets a unsupervised data set du and
a supervised data set
DS in un I said you only have the X's
but it comes from a distribution P of X
which is the marginal of pxy so PX and
pxy are from the same distribution it's
just in one case you don't get to see
the Y okay so just some data wasn't
labeled you didn't have the money or the
resources in some other way to also get
it labeled but it was collected in the
same way as your labeled
data so actually many interesting ideas
here um
and the way the lecture is building up
is the the last one noisy stent is the
one that uh has the best results but
actually brings together ideas from the
others and um all of these ideas kind of
tend to often be used together so let's
start with the simp simplest earliest
ones and we'll work our way
down so one way you could do semiu
learning is by doing entropy
minimization what's the intuition here
we're talking about the entropy of the
classifier so the classifier output say
law probability let's say of Y label
given X that's a distribution over y
given X that distribution has an entropy
associated with it if it's very
confident the entropy is low if it's
very ambiguous and doesn't really know
what the label should be entropy is high
it's closer to
uniform the reason entropy minimization
could make sense is the following idea
I'm going to train my classifier and I
wanted to be the case that on my data
points I don't have a decision boundary
because if I think all my data points
should belong to one class or the other
and there should be a clear separation
between the classes then none of my data
points should have the classifier doubt
between the two and so by putting this
minimization there essentially saying
when I draw my decision boundary between
the two classes draw it somewhere where
there's no data draw it in the empty
space between the data because that's
where it's more likely to be than
crossing right through a dense part of
the data and so op formally you have two
terms in your objective function you
minimize the classification loss and
then you minimize the the entropy now
note when this talk about intermediation
this is measured on your data point so
it's looking at for every data point
that's unlabeled what's the entropy of
your classifier on that data point and
so if you make it low on every data
point then your decision boundary will
be nowhere near any of your data points
which might or might not be the perfect
place to put it but that's the
Assumption here that there will be a
clean separation and you'll find it
through this
objective you can do a more gradual
version of this um which is maybe a
little bit more common um you train your
classifier y given X on the label data
and then you repeat you evaluate your
classifier y given X on unlabeled data
and then you assign pseudo labels for
the ones that are most confident let's
say the 10% most confident labels you
say okay I'm just going to trust the
classifier that these can now be treated
as labels for my next round of
classifier training
I train again and I repeat till all the
unlabeled data have also become
labeled so it's really a gradual version
of entropy minimization because you're
ultimately assigning a dedicated label
to each uh data point but you're kind of
growing out or visually you're growing
it out from things you know well to
Regions where you don't know as well and
that gradual growth might lead to a
better decision in terms of the areas
that are further away from your label
data points because you use the density
of your data to guide the way things are
growing and so think of this as a maybe
like a way of achieving entropy
minimization that is um a procedure that
might lead to better results just
because the way it's structured then
just straight up entropy minimization um
because you don't know what local
minimum you're going to fall into when
you do it just
directly Okay so we've seen enty
minimization directly in the objective
as alternative through pseudo labels
gradually then there's something else
you can do and this has been the core of
many of the most successful um recent
approaches is to just think about label
consistency with data augmentation so
whenever you train a classifier
typically you have a limited supply of
labeled images and uh where labeled or
unlabeled either way you can generate
augmentations you can say I'm going to
flip it and crop it I'm going to
grayscale it you can do all kinds of
things that don't change the label you
want to assign to this image this
augments your data set if everything's
labeled you just have a larger label
data set if some images are not labeled
you could still argue that the fact that
they're part of the data set come from
the same
distribution even if I don't know the
label these both should have the same
label not a different label because they
came from the same original and so this
is a invariant that I can also impose on
my my unlabeled data that augmentation
should not change the output of the
classifier on my unlabeled data and so
the way that's done is make sure that
the Logics of the classifier are
similar then you can do many many
augmentations obviously you can crop
things crop things out you can gray
scale you can do essentially a line
filter soell filter and so forth so all
of these are reasonable augmentations
that you might already be using on your
label data just also apply it to your
label
data
um so that that's the key idea and now
it's going to Incarnate in in a few
different ways so Pi
model Pi model says I have an example
which could be labeled or not labeled uh
so the Yi the dotted line shows that it
could be there could not be there
depending on it belongs to my labeled or
unlabeled data either way I have this
example I stochastic Al choose
augmentations so I'll have two different
augmentations of that
original then I'll feed it through my
neural network using Dropout why that
introduces yet more variation into how
these things get processed I get out the
logits called Z I get out two different
logic vectors one for each of the two
augmentations and then take a add a loss
function saying Z and Z till the I
should be close
together because it's augmentations of
the same original thing and now if I
have do have a label I also introduce
cross entropy
loss so this is
um in some
ways the simplest way to do this and
it's worth noting the connections with
things we talked about earlier think
about things like um
gradually expanding your label set this
is in some sense gradually expanding
your label set if you have a labeled
example you want different augmentations
of that labeled example to effectively
generate the same label because same
Logics if you have an unlabeled example
it's just trying to make sure that
within a region the classifier doesn't
really change quickly so this this kind
of thing the classifier should stay
rather consistent in its decisions Lo Al
around any example that you
have so this is the pseudo code version
um for each mini batch um you evaluate
the network outputs for the augmented
inputs then with different Dropout and
augmentation you have the supervised
loss component if the label is available
you have the unsupervised loss component
update the network parameters uh and
repeat now
one thing
that you might not really like about
this is that every time you have to
compute or go through your network twice
you have two augmentation you have to
process them both so as you iterate
through your data multiple rounds
multiple EPO through your data you're in
some sense doing a lot of work again and
again and maybe you can structure the
computation slightly differently so so
what's done here is essentially for each
data point you keep track of an time
averaged loged Vector so next time you
come through you remember what it was
the previous time and you try to stay
close to that with your new output of
logits so think of it as
a different way of getting access to a
different
augumentation it's a different
augmentation because it's always random
in the previous round you used a
different augmentation just randomly
ended up with a different one it was
also fed through a different network
namely the network from the previous
round before the last Epoch of updates
so that's also happening which in some
sense puts you a little bit behind but
maybe it's okay um uh maybe introduces
some nice smoothing
um that's the temporal version temporal
ensembling version of this
um what might you not like about this it
kind of assumes that for assumes two
things that there's this notion that you
you'll have a small enough data set that
you need run multiple epochs through it
otherwise this doesn't even make sense
and it assumes that you're willing to
keep around the average Logics
historically for each data example so in
addition to storing the example you
stored this additional piece of um um
information I guess with
it um here's the the pseudo code kind of
Ste through it already um so what's
another alternative rather than
storing the averaged logits for a
specific entry from um before um you
keep two models around so rather than
having logits for each data point that
you keep around you keep two neural Nets
around and one is the time
average some sense delayed exponential
moving average version of the other one
and so now you want both of them be
consistent you can think of that time
average one as lagging behind hence
producing the outputs from previous
augmentations you might have used in
some sense because it's trained based on
those augmentations so it's more similar
to those and has a similar effect to
doing new augmentations where you have
explicit pairs so this called mean
teacher so this case
um we have two models to keep around but
not to have to keep extra things around
with each data point um the other thing
is here that you don't need to wait for
um multiple epochs this works even if
you have only a single Epoch through all
your data um you can always have the you
know two models compare their their
outputs and be that part of the
loss to me these things are always a
little unsatisfactory even though it
works quite well just because
essentially putting a loss against the
time average version of yourself is a
bit of a kind of funny non not so
stationary objective until you in the
end converge I guess when when you're
all done um but um it is it is pretty
popular and I think Philip covered you
covered byol right which is a similar
idea for unsupervised learning where you
keep around a Time average version of
your your model historically to compare
the outputs with and bring them
close here's another approach
um advisal ad s examples are a thing
where you take a classifier and maybe
some image is a dog and you want the
classifier even though it gets it right
then now call it a cat and then you do a
grain propagation into the pixels rather
than into the weights to change the
pixel such that now the classifier
decides it's a
cat um that's for classification for the
purpose here the proposal is if you are
a label data point you don't want it to
be the case that anywhere near
you the decision boundary changes to a
different class label so you could say
okay then I need to fill the entire
sphere near me with additional data
points that have the same label as I
have myself or with random augmentations
try to get good coverage that's one way
to do it that's what we've looked at so
far in alternative to just run an
optimization say I'm going to run an
optimization within a small region in
which direction will my classifier
change the
most and you move in that direction
find the uh that now augmented data
point and you say it needs to have the
same logic as I have my original data
point has so it's essentially smoothing
out near data points how much the
classifier can change its
output okay so then there's this paper
um was done few years ago now realistic
evaluation of deep semi supervised
learning algorithms couple of things to
note about this paper we'll look at some
of the results that they highlighted one
of the things that was happening at the
time in semi supervisor learning is that
everybody was using different things it
was essentially you write a semi survice
learning paper you might even use a
different data set than the previous
people used even you Ed the same data
set they might have used it I don't know
a resonet 18 I use a resonet 152 and you
say oh mine is doing better than yours
but it's like okay well completely
different new net architecture is your
method better or was your N Net
architecture better we don't know um
part of it was just that the new net
architectures was changing so rapidly
that it was natural to use the latest
and greatest but as a consequence you
didn't know if it was the latest and
greatest architecture giving you better
results or your new idea giving better
results so they decided to do a careful
comparison they use the wide resonant um
to make sure the network is expressive
enough nothing is baling by the
expressiveness of the network
itself so they compared on C4 10 and SN
Carr 10 is like a 10-way classification
task and SN is I think a street view
house numbers classification
um there 4,000 and a th000 labeled
examples available for this
semi-supervised learning run in the data
sets there's a lot more labeled examples
but because semi surise learning wants
to use small number of labels and show
still good results um only part of the
labels were allowed to be used even
though the whole data set is available
as the unlabeled examples
supervised learning gets um in this case
20% error rate and 12% error rate so no
not terrible but not great the pi model
which is random augmentation keep the
Logics close together um 16 s so better
mean teacher which was this
approximation of the pi model where you
keep a
historical average um rather than um
explicitly redoing two augmentations
every time um turns out to be actually
slightly better than the P model so
something about this historical
averaging of your network seems to give
you a bit more uh interesting
signal um the adversarial training it's
called virtual virtual adversarial
training um did even better actually got
the best single method results and then
viral adversarial training with an
additional entropy minimization loss did
even a little bit better and pseudo
labeling um you know is kind of in the
same ballpark as most of the others so
what you see here is that maybe one
observation is they're all pretty
similar in performance but then if
you're really going to try to tease them
apart the vat is uh giving you the best
performance
here they did then a study how does that
vary across number of labeled data
points um because maybe some methods are
really good with a very small number of
labels and others better with large
number of labels who who knows turns out
that the trend is pretty consistent vat
is at at the bottom which is best um
consistently across the amount of label
data across both CFR 10 and
svhn so think of it essentially as a
very efficient way to smooth out the
classifiers the classifier function you
wanted to not have a steep slope be
roughly constant essentially around your
data points and vat does that by finding
the direction which it is still changing
the most and penalizing for that
effectively okay
so from there um qule and collaborators
at Google did a pretty big push on
trying to get on semi surviv learning to
work on larger scale settings moving it
from
c4n to imag net and there's sequence of
papers getting that done changing a
little bit how it's done but the some of
the key ideas really remain the same
it's still about data augmentation and
consistency that's somehow is the most
prevalent principle uh across all of
this these
days consistency meaning after data
augmentation the logits should be the
same or very close
together so apply State data
augmentation to unlabel data via
consistency training in semi survis
learning so at the time quar group had
made a lot of progress on advancing data
augmentation this for visual inputs
especially but also some for language
and um now I want to see if we actually
use the latest what does it do for
semi-supervised
learning so this slide from one of the
authors there um you have the label data
on which you have the supervised cross
entropy loss you have unlabel data on
which you might um add
augmentations vat is one type of
augmentation find find a change that
makes your classifier change the most
which of course you don't want the
classifier to change but by finding that
change you can add it as an example that
needs to keep the Logics the same um and
you have that unsurprised consistency
loss between the augmentation and the
original um you can also add noise to
regularize the model prediction in
addition so to just um having a vat and
then together they are combined for the
final
loss and the top row here is what they
show what happens when running this
uh for the two moons data set it nicely
expands the labels over time into the
regions that you want them to go and
then they had a baseline essentially
where that wasn't really
happening now vat is just one type of
augmentation in let's say language you
might want to do back translation which
is you translate to another language and
then translate back which gives you a
rephrasing of the sentence you already
have and so that new sentence should
mean roughly the same as the original
sentence and so that's now your
augmentation autoagent is a system
Google developed where you
have re some recoloring making images
darker brighter sharpening them cropping
them cropping things out slanting them
all kinds of augmentations for images um
that was also trained to find the right
mix that optimizes for classifier
performance um so that's Auto augment
and then tfidf word replacement means
essentially you have text and
essentially think of it as look up the
embeddings of the words and if you can
find another word with a very similar
embedding just swap it in and that's
your
augmentation so this examples we get
through back translation given the low
budget and production production
limitations this movie is very good
since it was a highly Limited in terms
of budget and the production
restrictions the film was cheerful so
that's the kind of thing you can hope
for um when you do this back and forth
translation as your data
augmentations um
so Auto augment essentially has a policy
that was trained with some limited form
of reinforcement learning to decide how
often to sample a rotation a brightness
transformation and so forth or
combinations there
off language experiments they compared
with at the time the state of yard in
language for classification let's say uh
sentiment analysis classification or
type of movie classification and so
fourth um Bert provided state of you
could train a Bert model which is a
leave out word prediction model that we
covered a couple lectures ago and then
you can put a classifier on top of Bert
to have uh a solution to this
classification problem so it's a UNS
supervised pre-training followed by a
fine-tuning now what they look at is
what if we don't have that many labeled
examples we're still going to pre-train
because pre-training seems a good idea
we shouldn't throw it away but instead
of having let's say 25k labeled examples
for IMDb we have 20 examples that's it I
believe in this case it's like one to
five stars so there's five possible
classification labels you have
essentially four of each and that's it
so a lot less data
available you can initialize the network
random bird base which is a smaller Bird
model bird large and then bird uh fine
tune and what you see here is
that um fine tune which is what uses a
semi-supervised learning for fine tuning
gets the best performance across the
board compared to anything else before
including better than uh the bird large
model trained with more label data a lot
more label data so what this tells us is
that all the label data we have in these
data
sets the labels don't carry that much
information the information is more in
the inputs than the outputs because the
semi-supervised learning is essentially
saying I can mostly ignore the labels I
can figure it out on my own where the
density is and where to put the decision
boundary based on that um it's pretty
interesting to see that that's the case
FS have a little protection against
overtraining as you training you don't
want to have your loss put too much
emphasis on a small number of examples
and to really try to fit them as well as
possible keep improving your loss so
once you exceed a certain threshold of
label confidence it's taken out of the
loss function to not uh have too much
influence on on the outcome so it's like
treat all your data points somewhat
equally I guess in terms of importance
don't let anyone Dominate and they have
different schedules and turns out that
different schedules were more beneficial
uh different schedule for language than
for image which is kind of unfortunate
that they didn't have the same optimal
schedule but uh that is how it came out
in in their
work um previous state-ofthe-art
projector is not happy for some
reason previous state-ofthe-art in red
this is on
IMDb sentiment rating classification of
movement
um
semi-supervised approach is actually
outperforming the fully supervised
approach which is pretty
exciting Vision experiments they did at
the time um they looked at the previous
state of the yart um is again CFR and
svhn which were 7.6 3.53 and they're
able to dive right below that um with
this unsurprised data augmentation and
then if they use even bigger neur neural
networks more refined neural networks
for these problems they could do even
better than that so clearly also the
neural net architecture still mattered a
lot at the time to keep
refining
um they also looked at
um essentially what they looked at here
is how close you can get with 4,000
labeled examples compared to
50,000 once you use this semi-supervised
learning um the other 46,000 examples
are used without your label just to be
clear you still have them available just
not the label um and it turns out that
that works you get very close to when in
the case you do have the
labels um they tested against you know
different augmentation techniques and
realize that the being really good at
the augmentation scheme is important cuz
timately drives what you want to be
similar you're saying I want these two
to be similar that's my that's what my
augmentation is telling me um and it
matters how good a scheme you have for
that imag net they tried also and got
some very good results there um the
unlabeled data here is also image net
data so you get 10% of the data remains
labeled 90% becomes unlabeled and of
course can help through semi- supervised
learning compared to just doing supervis
supervised on the 10% gives you you 55
bringing the 90% other unlabeled data
gets you to 68% top one
accuracy they then tried to augment it
even with more data they took a private
Google data set JF jft um that didn't
really help um so what you see here is
that somehow this assumption semi-
supervised learning that the unlabeled
data comes from the same distribution
and that's why you can kind of move your
decision boundary to the right spot
based on just having a few labels when
it comes from very different
distribution uh it doesn't seem to do
much for
you um they looked at the learning rates
um no not the learning the how much they
mask out certain data points when the
classifier is um above a certain
confidence level and see here for a text
data set you better to use the expon
cial schedule for image data set better
use the linear
schedule so data augmentation is very
effective as a perturbation for
semi-supervised learning as a way to
essentially feel out where the density
is and then put your decision Bounder in
the right spot UDA significant improves
for both language and vision compared to
previous Works combines well with
transfer learning you could pre-trend on
bird and still get um well use a preent
model namely bird and still get benefits
on top
that from there um the Google group then
looked at something um very related but
that a little bit different it works a
little bit better they said instead of
bringing the logits together for
different
augmentations look at the different
logic outputs from the different
augmentations take the average of
them and then increase well decrease the
temperature a little bit sharpen the
distribution just a little
bit and use that as your target for all
of
them so you can think a little bit it's
a bit like bit like pseudo labeling it's
like you know I have some guesses at
labels I'm going to sharpen those
guesses a little bit I'm going have
multiple guesses combine them to come to
that thing that I want to sharpen and I
am trying to bring all the outputs
together but not bring it together by
saying close to each other but bringing
them close to an average of them which
is kind of the same as bringing them
close together
um but it's just slide tweak on it and
allows you to also introduce that
sharpening
operation they also did something else
that I always found pretty pretty funny
but somehow it it kind of works you you
Sally what they
do you take two data points straight up
in pixel space and you average
them and then you also average their
labels meaning
um if it's a cat and a dog then now you
have 50% cat 50% dog by just averaging
the two images and that becomes a new
labeled example it's called mixup um I
always thought it was a little crazy to
expect that that would do anything good
I think the intuition here is that you
essentially force your neural network to
find a simplest possible way to get to
the answer like you want it to be you
know not do something complicated but
stay as close as possible to what's
already in the pixels to then reach the
answer because the closer you stay to
the original information the more
averaging will just kind of work out so
smoothing it's like a smoothing of
um essentially the where you want to end
up with your neural
network here's the the full version so
what do they do they say we have X is
label data U represents unlabeled data
so you have your label data you do an
augmentation or multiple unlabel data
you do data augmentation on that too
then you do the operation of averaging
the logits and sharpening them and now
for each of these data points you have a
Target
output you have those Target originally
labeled data with now with augmentations
and Target outputs unlabel data that are
now augmentations there off with their
target outputs
then you essentially this is just like a
I guess a coding version of it but
conceptually you essentially take
randomly a labeled unlabeled you mix
them and generate a new example that's
literally the average of The Originals
and the label is also the average of The
Originals so this operation here this
mixup operation is applied at the very
end of this data generation process and
this whole thing doesn't even train a
classifier all this is doing is turning
your labeled and unlabeled data into
augmented versions with sharpened
average logits and then doing the mixup
operation to get yet new data at the
interpolation of your original data so
some better coverage of the space is
generated that way with targets
associated with it once you're done with
that then you train with cross entropy
loss for the labeled examples and um the
the lodged um proximity loss for um the
unlabeled
examples um what you see here is that
um mix match what this is called in
black is actually better than the
methods we we looked at so far um the
best one before is vat virtual
adversarial training not nearly as good
in yellow compared to the black curve
over here so kind of a complicated
procedure but um it happens to work very
well um more more compar not sure the
Details Matter essentially looking
across the number of labels you have
available um seeing that the mix match
kind of generally is giving the best
results across label uh
percentages then we're on to the best
model
today still I think um noisy Student
Self train with noisy
student so this was the first Model to
truly achieve this and we'll see that in
the final curves of from their paper
really able to consistently have
semi-supervised outperform supervised
across the
board so what they do they have
data they do dma data augmentation
dropout castic depth in a network mean
that sometimes you essentially skip over
a layer because these are networks with
skip connections that you just don't
even do you don't pass through the skip
you forget about the actual things
that's happening in that layer um so
stochastic depth that way um train
student model with combined so all of
that stuff is happening on your
data you train a model on
that then
you
go to your unlabeled data you infer
pseudo labels meaning the ones where you
are most
confident you assign a
label after you've done that you go
back
and train with those labels so so far
all I've said is data augmentation and
pseudo labeling now the thing that
really matters is when you go back and
train you ask to use should be more
clear here actually as you do the INF
for labels you just use a straight up
image when then you train you use data
orientation drop out stochastic depth
the way to think of it is that if your
image stayed clean and nothing happened
to it for a few of these you became
confident you could know the
label now you're
saying if I do a lot of transformation
to the image if I put a lot of noise in
the processing of my neural network I
should still be confident about this
label so you're forcing effectively
Network to not just be com about the
specific image but the entire region
around that image once you're done with
that your network knows a lot more than
just that label it knows now the whole
region around that example effectively
you go again you look at the remaining
unlabeled examples see which ones you're
now confident about and repeat so it's
in some of this kind of a specific
incarnations of ideas that we already
covered it's pseudo labeling with this
notion of
um of them training in a way that's much
noisier once you have the pseudo labels
also the pseudo labels are not hard
classifications they are the Logics that
you're trying to to
match um bit more details here theya is
now on imag net so they really want to
show that this can work across the curve
image net is the real data and you're
going to have unlabel data on the side a
bigger version of jft 300 million
unlabeled images and the hope is to see
that no matter how many labeled examples
we have from imet because we also have
this other unlabeled data set available
we're going to get something that's
always better than only supervised
learning on the um provided imag net uh
data noisy student um achieves 88.4% the
best previous version um achieved 86% so
it is indeed doing um doing
better
um so they actually succeeded at what
they set out to do I think this curve is
really what rung at home is show that
consistently this noisy student version
outperforms any other kind of successes
past successes on imag net uh top one
accuracy uh
performance horizontal axis here is the
size of the network so as you grow a
bigger Network you get better
performance um but here you see
consistent ly noisy student training
gives you the best performance compared
to Prior uh
methods okay um and then they looked at
so there are versions of imet that are
harder um that have been released and so
they show consistently also on these
harder versions of imet that you get the
best performance with this noisy student
approach
um
yeah so in summary sary supervised
learning is a practically important
problem for two scenarios lots of label
data and a lot more unlabeled data or
very little labeled data and plenty of
unlabeled data
historically the bottom thing is what
people have studied but this
noisy noisy student version has shown
that even the first version uh is now
possible to achieve success with so it's
pretty
exciting
so these are two disjoint Topics by the
way they're just both shorter topics
that's why they're in one lecture
together um so the second half topic
here is unsupervised distribution
alignment what's the problem
setting we have access to samples from a
distribution over some variable a and
also sample from distribution over
variable B but no access to Joint
samples between A and B okay we somehow
need to estimate how to go from a from a
from B to a and from A to
B all right one example could be
translation you have a corpus of text in
English a corpus of text in whale
language to be very
specific and how do you from just having
those separate corpuses find a way to
translate between the two now that might
be pretty hard because it might be a bit
of a
large difference in what whales talk
about what we talk about but imagine
English and French um we don't have to
do it that way because we have paired
sentences available but intellectually
you could ask the question can we from
just the Corpus of English and just the
Corpus of French find a translation
between the
two this could be for style transfer
maybe have a corpus of images that are
real images other images that are
paintings of a certain style and you
want to find a translation between the
two um there are other ways to do this
by essentially language conditioning and
so forth but in this situation here
we're hoping to have just two different
data sets effectively in different
domains in some sense and you want them
to somehow find find a match between
them how to
transfer you can also do augment labeled
example so if you had a way to for
example exle go from between regular
images and segmented images those are
two different distributions and you
found a translation between the two you
can start automatically labeling uh new
images with segmentations so that's
that's the problem we're looking to
solve I person think is one of the most
intriguing like intellectual problems to
look at and kind of the simplest case of
this of course would be something
where somebody writes text but they have
a cipher they use where they permute the
letters from A through Z they have a
permutation when I my word has an A in
it I'm going to write it as a c let's
say and it has a b in it write it as a d
and then the question becomes can you
find the permutation that I used to
recover what I was writing and you could
imagine that if I write in English and
then apply that permutation to it that
you could recover it after you see
enough of my writing you say well
there's often this three letter thing
happening what are the most frequent
threel words in English maybe the what's
the most frequent single letter word in
English maybe it's a and so you can
start seeing like maybe you know find
some pieces of the puzzle that come
together and from there find other
pieces of the puzzle that's kind of more
like a human approach to to try to solve
these kinds of puzzles but that's
effectively the the puzzle we're trying
to solve you have this unaligned data
but you know that there should be some
alignment in some way or other and you
try to find
it so as I said this could be relevant
for machine translation especially for
languages where maybe we don't have
match corpuses it's just a language that
other spoken by animals might be harded
over with distribution mismatch but uh
language is spoken by smaller
populations who maybe haven't written as
many books and so forth um and
definitely haven't written paired text
between their language and another
language
um this is another example from some of
the papers on this you have images
taking daytime images taking night time
uh these are obviously not uh perfectly
matched up but there are I mean you
could see this is a pretty good
translation in terms of turning this
daytime image into a much darker version
of it um and so you probably wouldn't
have available that's another thing you
probably wouldn't have available image
daytime and then same spot image
nighttime you just have a bunch of
daytime images and a separate bunch of
nighttime images and so it's U it's not
about finding a onetoone mapping between
data points in the one data set and data
points in the other set it's about
finding somehow a correspondence between
these distributions
overall here this is from actually alosa
group couple years ago they have like
one data set is photo the other one is
Mon and then they could ask it to learn
to translate from one to the other um
including doing translations for images
that Monet didn't make paintings for but
then you could turn it into a
corresponding Monet
painting um they did it with zebras and
horses where you could turn zebra into
horse once you're done training or horse
into zebra even though nobody ever gave
you a pair data set of how you turn this
horse into a zebra
specifically so recall the problem
setting we have access to samples from
PA and PB without any access to samples
from The Joint but we need to estimate
the conditional to go between
them and by the way the conditional
could really be a distribution could
really be that given a b there is many
possible A's and it's a distribution
over possible A's and in other settings
it could be that what you expect to find
is something deterministic like given
this specific B this is the
corresponding a that's it uh both cases
are interesting and
relevant
okay so there are really two key ideas
that people have applied um marginal
matching is one of those two
ideas we try to learn the relationship
between A and B so trying to find
approximation of a given B with some
parameterized newon netw Q Theta a given
B and same for the other way around we
try to find a q Theta B given
a what do we have available to us as
information we know that
if we start
from an original distribution let's say
in a space and then we use the
transformation to go to b space It
should match the marginal distribution
in b space and the other way around if
we start from the Marg distribution over
B we do the transformation we should get
the correct marginal distribution over a
um as I said sometimes done with
theistic mappings that's your choice of
neural network but in general this could
be a probabalistic mapping uh to try to
do this okay so let me draw an example
on the board um so
imagine I had my a space and
my b space
effectively um and these are pro this is
really probability for specific a
probability for specific B and a could
take on the value let's say I don't know
um
Alpha Beta or gamma and B could take on
the values maybe you know one two or
three and let's say the probabilities
respectively are maybe Alpha has a
probability
of
0.1 beta has a probability
0.3 and Gamma has a probability
of
0.6 and now let's say here this one has
a probability of
0.6 two has a probability
of 0.1 and three is a probability of
0.3 in this case it should be clear that
there's a natural solution to this
problem right you should want Alpha to
match with two beta to go to three and
Gamma to land at one because if you do
that if that's how you map then starting
from the distribution over a going
through the mapping you will indeed end
up with a correct 0.6 here a correct 0.1
here and a correct 0.3 here so you're
Landing with the right probability mass
in each spot if that's the mapping you
use any other mapping will not land well
I the theistic map will not land the
right probability Mass there are other
stochastic mappings that could also get
you the right probability Mass you could
decide that gamma let's say splits in
some way between some of the others and
same for beta and Alpha you could still
get the correct Mass but likely the
simplest solution is the one that might
make most sense to want to end up with
would be the specific deterministic
mapping so it's very feasible
intuitively in some sense that by
knowing that we want the marginal to
match up after the transformation that
in certain scenarios in this specific
scenario in certain scenarios it
determines a natural solution and if we
keep our Neal Nets simple it'll
hopefully then find the natural solution
which is simple to represent compared to
something more complicated Yeah question
um I'm not sure I just feel we're making
a like assumptions about as well as the
distribution seeing these distributions
don't that helping
so the question is I mean are we making
a lot of assumptions here yeah I'm
giving you an example a very specific
example where we can naturally infer a
solution okay now for real data sets
often it's hard to visualize them often
is not completely impractical to
visualize them this way but I'm saying
that if we think about a very simple
example where both A and B are spaces
where the variable can only take on
three values and if the marginals are
such that there is a permutation that
matches one on the other there is a very
natural solution so this concept of
marginal matching at least for certain
data sets imposes a certain solution um
or a set of solutions if you allow it to
be stochastic but if you want something
simple deterministic you're only left
with one possible solution here and in
some sense that's similar to let's say
we go from English to French if the
French and the English actually had a
grammatically slightly more lined up
language and talked about the same
things equally often then that's all you
need to do you just need to find the
permutation that Maps the words
correctly even though you never saw
supervision because they talk
effectively the same stories and once
you look at the marginals you should be
able to line things up but it's a very
very specific assumption absolutely but
it's a nice starting point to know that
at least under these assumptions things
can work pretty well I think often when
you do something new it's not to go to
very simple cases and even in a simple
case it doesn't make sense you're you're
in a lot of trouble because then maybe
it'll never make sense
um by the way it could also be ambiguous
and this goes back to your question
really what if instead of this it was
lined up
as 0.3 also for gamma and then there is
a Delta which also has
0.3 what now right how do I go from A to
B which one goes where even for
restricting to a deterministic mapping
well two of them would go to the 0.6
Mass here and one of them would go there
but I have many options on how to do
that on the way back also have many
options on how to go back and this one
definitely would have to be stochastic
is have to be split but even then
there's many options on how to go back
so even when there's a little bit of
change this kind of you know in some
sense token for token permutation
Exchange is problem not giving us
everything we want um so It's Tricky it
doesn't
always work necessarily but um and
there's other things in fact if we talk
about marginal matching I
could I could for
example match the
marginals by and I'll make it even
simpler to get the point
across I'll give it a fourth
M3 over here that's four it's also
0.3 I could go Alpha to two that seems a
natural choice I could go beta to one I
could go gamma to three and it could go
Delta to four but then when I come back
I could go instead of two well two goes
back to Alpha that's kind of the only
choice but then one instead of going
back to Beta I could decide to go to
Delta
and three instead of going back to gamma
I could go
to um beta and from four I could go to
gamma so what I'm trying to highlight
here is that marginal matching imposes
some information on what you want to end
up with but even for simple relatively
simple cases like this it doesn't even
impose the notion that if I go this way
and I come back I should land in the
same spot I'm only asking the
distributions to stay the same
so the second principle people uh have
prevalently used here is cycle
consistency if you go from A to B
specific a to a specific B you should
come back to that same a on the round
trip um you shouldn't be like going in
weird
inconsistencies um so in the case of a
deterministic mapping apply a
transformation to a to land in b space
and then apply the other the opposite
transformation you should land back back
and a and same for B this dramatically
reduces the number of
possibilities so these are the two
principles that kind of prevail across
all these methods marginal matching
cycle
consistency um so what we talked about
Marin matching allow for this weird
solution once we and force C consistency
one has to go back to Beta and then
three has to go back to gamma and four
has to go back to Delta we have no
choice once we make these choices here
so the solution space is
reduced so we've covered two invariances
that we know hold true marginal matching
and Cy consistent we also know that
they're not enough to have unique
Solutions but we know that at least it'd
be good for them to be true um
they're not enough in general so you
need to introduce more inductive biases
things that you know about how the two
distributions might match up um maybe in
your architecture maybe in your loss
function maybe in how you select data
from both sides um to make this work
right you can imagine if you try to line
up French with English maybe you could
choose certain books let's say right if
it's a book written about a certain
Topic in English maybe on physics and
not a book written in French about
physics maybe there's a higher chance
you can find the alignment than if you
just take a random text in English
random text in French to learn the
alignment same with whales I guess you
have to think hard about what goes on in
whale lives and then maybe somebody
writes about that writes like
effectively a movie script about whales
talking to each other in a realistic way
and then maybe all of a sudden you can
actually um match it up get the chicken
and egg problem because who's going to
write that script without having first
known what they're talking about but you
need to do some work to maximize your
chances of success
here so what do you think about um like
multimodal
alignment yeah multimodal align so it's
very interesting so um you're absolutely
right go from the speech to to the you
know we have like video videos of the
whales interacting at that those times
yeah I mean mean I think the more you
can Infuse the better and this is also
what we see in language alignment um and
image alignment it's never done at the
pixel level it's never done at just the
word word level it's done by taking
larger context and try to align
sentences try to align entire images or
image patches and so same thing if you
can have multimodal it should work even
better if you think about just human
languages you know way to think about it
you know if somebody is I don't know uh
maybe um
drinking a a cup of coffee or something
maybe they're more likely to talk about
the same thing as somebody else drinking
a cup of coffee and so the alignment
there you might bias it to wor those
more likely be lined up what's being
said at that time same thing maybe if
somebody raises their voice of course
different languages are different but
maybe raising your voice is an
indication of something that's more
likely aligned with in another language
somebody raising their voice so I think
the more you can bring in the better
it's going to work
yes
so one of the most famous works in this
space actually done by alos fris group
here at Burkley called cycle
Gan and what it comes down to is how
essentially using
Gans to impose the marginal matching and
impose the cyle
consistency um because I say we need to
do margin matching we need to do c
consistency on an example drawn on the
board that's easy enough but you have
two data sets of images how do you even
do marginal matching how do you even do
cycle consistency that becomes the
question so how did they do it or
proposed to do it um they said for
marginal matching what we do is we have
a discriminator when you put something
into the other domain the result of that
let's say a newly generated image will
have a discriminator loss on it and
should be indistinguishable from other
images in that domain so that means
you're generating things that come from
the right distribution and so if you do
this fully correctly you should get the
right thing now of course often you make
approximations your discriminator
doesn't look at the entire distribution
it just looks at one example at a time
just like we saw with regular ganss but
this notion that once you do your
transformation a discriminator is going
to evaluate whether it looks like it
comes from the right distribution or not
that's the marginal
matching then C consistency they did
with essentially just going through the
mapping twice and see if you landed back
where you started from just the L1 loss
I go to the other domain come back I
need to be back where I started
from that's a very interesting
assumption right because imagine you are
trying to do cons cycle consistency
between um you know I don't know uh a
data set with
um you know one type of animal horse
versus zebra might match pretty well cuz
all I need to do is change the texture
you can come back but if it were
something that doesn't match as closely
now you need to find weird
correspondences like what does it mean
for a horse to be in a certain pose that
matches the pose of a human because you
go from let's say horse to human and
back like what does that even mean
what's how do you encode the pose the
horse was in and how you pose the human
and still have the human be in
distribution for human images right and
so what you can imagine happening is
that your data sets are kind of
misaligned you essentially this thing
starts hiding information in weird
places and little high frequency
patterns that are you know for the
discriminator hard to distinguish but
then encode information that you can
bring back into the other domain which
they also discovered happens if you're
not careful
um but essentially what they showed is
that um sackle Gan uh if you look at per
pixel accuracy going so this is one
domain is images the other one is
segmentations you can say why not just
train in a supervised way from image to
corresponding segmentation well they
just wanted to test their approach they
said let's take a data set has images
and segmentations and let's TR put them
in separate uh data sets effectively and
find the correspondences and they found
that they had the best
effectively it's not exactly
unsupervised because you do have
segmentations in the other part of the
data but you're not supervised about the
correspondences and that they can do
better than previous unsupervised uh
segmentation approach is where you
pre-train and then have let's say uh the
embedding determine the the pixel level
segmentation um they also looked at what
happens when you remove some things so
what if you only use the cycle go back
and forth that doesn't do so well when
you do the Gan alone means good
marginals that's pretty good Gan plus
forward cycle actually hurts it a little
bit which is weird again plus backwards
cycle completely destroys it which which
is kind of interesting that these things
can can happen somehow uh but then the
whole thing works works the best um so
definitely some weird things happening
here um it does seem the Gan part is
somehow um the most important part
meaning the marginal matching being
imposed is the most important part to
make this
succeed the Cycles alone just don't get
it done I mean it should be kind of
logical that the Cycles alone don't get
it done because with just a you can
essentially go to the other domain you
don't even need to be in
distribution so if you don't need to be
in distribution you pretty much just
copy your own image nobody's going to
complain there's no no nothing saying
you have to stay in distribution and you
just copy it back and you learn nothing
so it's somewhat understandable that
cycle alone does pretty poorly to
actually find the match between the two
domains I think the weird thing is that
introducing the backward cycle
essentially kills it if you don't also
have the forward cycle but yeah
so you can do things like this input is
a segmented image output becomes a you
know realistic image um you could have
Edge images go into realistic images um
or the other way around realistic images
into Edge
images um you go from apples to oranges
oranges to Apples so summertime winter
time so that's very interesting the
these things do kind of work on certain
settings these are pretty specific
settings obviously um apples and oranges
are somewhat interchangeable in how they
tend to like get to be stacked together
and so forth so
um for the right kind of data it seems
like there's something here that can
really
work um failure cases that they also
showcased uh you know going from a Monet
to a photo in this case completely
failed from winter to summer didn't
really go to summer so it's not they
pretty uh upfront about uh limitations
in the
paper then there was another work that
said okay the tricky thing is if you go
back and fourth you impos that L1 loss
you're essentially looking for a
deterministic mapping which is very
limiting deterministic mapping um is um
not always feasible a single
segmentation could have many
incarnations as a real Street Scene the
street scene typical has one
segmentation but so often in one of the
directions you want something that's a
distribution rather than
deterministic so they said oh we should
introduce a lat variable Z and so I go
from one domain to the other while also
sampling a latent variable Z that I
condition on that helps me have a
stochastic output rather than
deterministic and this is essentially
everything we've done in this class has
done that same trick you want
distribution you condition on a z that's
randomly sampled and now you get more
possible things out of your system
rather than just a deterministic uh
come
um what would happen with the cycle
consistency losses is that effectively
if you're not
careful
um essentially the problem is that if
you don't know the Z that was
used when you try to go back you have no
way to go back you you need the
information from that Z to to be able to
work your way back and so introduce all
a variational inference Network to um
help recover the Z an estimate of the Z
effectively to to help you land back
onto the right spot um so that's that's
a small variation that um exists when
you really want the the probalistic
mappings then they talk about this thing
where it can cheat meaning
essentially it would do weird things
which we highlight a lot at the time not
sure if it's still really critical today
but you go from an edge image to all
kinds of different um shoes which is
great um but then um it turned out if
you went from shoe to Edge image back to
shoe you always got the same shoe back
and so what that indicated was that when
you turn something into an edge image
you were like hiding somewhere in the
edges a little bit of information to
tell it what she would came from and
allowing it to recover it so there are
subtle things you need to be aware of I
think as always with Gans there's always
these subtle things that are
um the results kind of are promising but
at the same time it's very tricky to get
them to do things exactly the way you
want them to do
them
um so you can ask a question can we do
better um we have marginal matching with
have cycle
consistency um what can we do that could
possibly be better
usually these domains as I've alluded to
are high dimensional you have image or
text that is a paragraph or at least a
sentence so maybe we shouldn't be trying
to do it at too low a level we should do
it at a bigger picture level and we can
get better alignment to arrive from that
so um let's say look at NLP a is all
English sentences b is all French
sentences two semantically unrelated S A
and B might have the same
frequency so if you swap the sentences
for each other it works out but if you
look deeper at the
words it might not work out because
these words also appear in other
sentences and then all of a sudden the
the thing doesn't work out anymore so
the idea is really to do simultaneously
try to get consistency at the word level
and at the sentence level all of a
sudden a better matching might emerge so
multi-level in some sense uh marginal
matching is the high level idea the
first time this was shown to be uh
successful and and actually was very
surprising to people at the time people
would train this thing called skipgram
Model the idea here is that you take
text and instead of doing just next
token prediction you take a point in
your text take a word and train a model
to predict the preceding words and the
following words obviously going to be a
pretty high entropy distribution but
that's what you train
that model that you train essentially
what it predicts for the preceding and
and previous words it has to do it by
generating an embedding of your word so
you have to embed your word into a
vector space and then the probability of
a certain word being right in front of
you is determined by the inner product
of your embedding with the embedding of
that other word so it's a way to
essentially Force embeddings to become
meaningful in terms of predictors of who
comes before you after after you that's
a skip gram model you do that you get
something pretty wild to emerge at least
I still think this pretty crazy um if
you do this on this case I think is um
maybe um Spanish and and English um you
get effectively word embeddings that are
set up in a way of projec them into
lower Dimension you can see that they
have the same shape and that the words
are relatively to each other in the
right location um and so all you need to
do is effectively rotate them onto each
other to you have three languages they
all end up with their own embeddings and
all we need to find is that final
rotation to translation rotation to put
them on top of each other which I think
before this experiment nobody would have
expected that would actually be true but
it's actually uh uh it's actually the
case that's what they
found so just to recap what was done is
essentially you try to find the word
embedding that makes that word embedding
predictive of the words coming before
and after it so you're both doing
embedding of the word and the embedding
has to be predictive of everything
around you so it's both like the low
level the word has an embedding and it
has to be consistent at at the sentence
level and it just emerges um this is
without even doing any work about
alignment this is completely unsurprised
distribution you completely separately
run it on both languages there's nothing
like C consistency being imposed during
that initial training there's no
marginal matching imposed during the
initial training you just unvis training
on each side independently and then do a
quick match at the
end um yeah some of this work is
actually right now this this name might
look familiar lpo is one of the
co-founders of mistol which is one of
the leading uh language models he did
some of this work back when it was still
at um meta faceb back in 2018 yeah
questions Ellie how does
alignment or rotation actually done
actually I don't remember the details of
how the rotation is done but if I were
to just make it up on the spot um you
have your embeddings you probably choose
some of the most frequent words a long
list of most frequent words and you find
a rotation Matrix translation rotation
that gets you from one to the other or
if you can do it on all words but
mightbe too high dimensional you do it
on all of them so finding a translation
rotation between two rigid sets of
points um
isn't too hard so it's not that they use
like one of these other methods that we
talked about treating like let's say
like one of these
like I don't think they did a cycle
consistency no they just did it
independently and then found that it
matches up
beautifully yes so are they doing exact
point matching or are they just finding
like the manifold around each of these
sets of embeddings and then matching the
Mana cuz from the picture it's kind of
misleading to me right they highlight
that whole area and there's not
necessarily points all across that
manifold that's being formed so are they
doing like a manifold matching or actual
pointwise matching I can't tell just
because of that highlighted region
around I don't remember for sure but if
I were to make a a guess right now they
pick as I said a bunch of words that
they line up find a translation rotation
that lines those up as well as possible
and then show that by lining up just
those because these embedding spaces are
so good essentially all the the words
are naturally very well lined up
too
yes in the alignment I think like a lot
of ways that people recall like it show
the algebra holds true
like the emding space of words like like
the way man and woman and King and like
make this Al you did not
that yeah that's a good point there
there was more capabilities to the word
and Bings Beyond cross language
alignment
mhm is simar
for those that's a good question those
didn't exist at that well they must have
just existed at that time but maybe not
long enough for them to try it also on
on that my my hunch is that it should be
very similar there because essentially a
bird model he's doing the same kind of
work has to do less work it's more
difficult to build a good distribution
maybe of everything around around you
than just fill in a blank when most of
it is known because that's a more
deterministic problem which is usually
easier um but yeah probably it would
work for those other models
too then it shows that by using this
essentially unsupervised uh alignment
they can improve the performance of the
machine translation system that they
have because you can bring in
effectively uh more training data in in
some sense
um now I want to switch gears for the
last little part here which is I think
the tricky thing with Gans has been
there's always a little catches get him
to work and there's a new thing we
proposed uh last year Asha Wilson howu
and and myself
um which is saying if we need to
do distribution alignment if we go to
the other space we want it to be aligned
with the distribution in the other space
instead of putting a gan discriminator
on it we we can do something else what
we can do instead is what's shown in the
the middle here is we go from image to
text back to image so that's a cycle
consistency but we want it to be
distribution line we don't want some
random English blurb to decide not to
encode with the words elephant because
you know why not use the word elephant
for this thing we wanted to use the
right words to describe let say you know
bird sitting on grass or something right
and so what's done is this image is
encoded is
then after he's done the image
encoding the network turns it into
English so it becomes a caption
effectively of that image but we have no
captioning supervision zero captioning
supervision it just has to turn it into
a sequence of tokens that's English
tokens once that's done to make sure
it's distributionally aligned um mask
out a bunch of the tokens use a Frozen
um Mas language model to fill back in
the
blanks and then
decode in the ideal case it encodes it
into correct clean English we mask
things out but the
Frozen Mass language model knows how to
fill things back in so it's a perfect
deterministic Channel all information
gets passed through it's nice
reconstruction should be easy of the
original image if on the other hand the
encoder here decides to use English in a
very unusual way that doesn't match the
way distribution over English language
is in typical English language then
after the masking this Frozen masked uh
language model will not be able to fill
back in the correct substitutes for the
blanks because it's out of distribution
English which gets masked and now it
doesn't know how to fill it back in so
it's going to fill in something wrong
cuz this one's Frozen you can't can't
turn it's going to fill out something
wrong here and now you have a very noisy
channel from input to Output which means
that it's much harder to reconstruct the
original
image and so this is a replacement for
the marginal matching to be clear it's
still the idea of marginal matching and
cycle consistency but the marginal
matching is done by having a essentially
pre-trained error correction model in
one of the spaces and then when you go
to that space introduce
noise apply the pre-trained error
correction model to get back on if you
did things right and then it's easy to
decode I think this is actually very
promising
um because for example one one class
project ride you you're working on doing
this potentially for language to
language for example you could imagine
that um agents are talking to each other
and you want them to talk in English to
each other not in some agent only
language and if you just let the
language emerge among themselves just
like different populations have had
different language emerg these agents
will probably have a different language
emerge of their own because they're in
their own world um but if you force them
to go through this
noising D noising step where the D
noising is only successful if you speak
English all of a sudden the agents will
be encouraged to speak English and now
agent to agent communication becomes
English communication rather than some
new language that didn't exist uh
before yeah this kind of means you only
need are it's a good question
meaning your question is we haven't done
that experiment um but it's interesting
experiment just look at an English
Corpus a French Corpus and see if this
approach allows you to build a
translation
system it very well might I mean in
principle it should
um yeah thisise like if you add some
noise to the IM you still able to get a
good yeah it's a good question if you
add noise to the image
um I mean to a great extent it depends
on
maybe well there's two ways to think
about resistance to noise one is in the
Reconstruction law if you put noise on
the input and you want to reconstruct a
d noise you essentially have a diffusion
process happening along the way too to
get a cleaner version out um which is
probably trainable but a bit harder so
you have a more difficult problem um you
also then need to maybe a little bit
careful about the loss you impose
because if your loss is very much at
the high fre if the higher frequencies
play a big role in your loss then maybe
takes a long time before it also picks
up on the more interesting structure in
the image um if you put noise on the
image after training and then hope that
it still captions correctly because
essentially UNS supervised captioning
learning right um my you better put it
on during training too otherwise it's
probably going to be not as robust when
you use it as an unsupervised captioner
um but other than not I'm not sure it
would be an
issue yeah I mean there's other
questions by the way is like how many
tokens do you even want for your
language I think we used about 100 do
you remember Wilson the exact number was
it 100 or 200 tokens somewhere that
ballpark right 26
26 yeah 256 tokens um so people say
image is a thousand words turns out in
this work it was image is 256 tokens and
tokens are less than a word so um you
know maybe maybe image is not always a
thousand words I mean it's a bit
subjective depends on your data set but
you do have to make choices there too so
there's definitely some choices to be
made still but I guess there's less
concern Maybe of like weird quirks that
Gans can have where um somehow you have
a game theoretic equilibrium that you
don't like and it's hard to to get to
the one you
want okay this is actually it for today
we have a shorter lecture um see you all
in two weeks
thanks okay